you're finishing the tour in Miami now
that is where the next Super Bowl is
going to be yes and I can't imagine a
better person for that suppose is that a
dream of yours you do it yeah we thought
about the Super Bowl
um and in that it's in Miami is a big
deal but you know we'll see you know
they make their own decisions over there
we all cried watching your Torah diary I
love that you're sharing that much but
that not this past episode but the one
before that where you were having a you
were all upset off your performance and
Alex completely conjured a no has anyone
ever been able to he was my hero that
night he says he was he was the MVP as
they say he really was has anybody ever
been able to like Center you and calm
you the way that he's able to do like
that no I mean I think because of what
he's done and performing on such a big
stage and you know and with the Yankees
all over the United States he he
understands my life in a way that nobody
else really has and and we come from
similar backgrounds and we just we
really have a special connection that
way so yeah he was he was amazing that
you said that's why I'm marrying he's so
sweet and caring which made me think how
emotional are his wedding that was going
to be like are they gonna be in saying
I'm gonna be solving I don't know I
don't know both of us are just like
standing up straight and don't think all
right so the blackout the evacuation on
Saturday what's your first thought when
that's happening you kind of tried to
fight it you were like we can't leave
and so would you have tried to go on
what yeah you know this happened to me
one time at the Staples Center I was
performing with pitbull we were closing
i heart radio show or you know one of
the radio stations and all the lights
went out
you know we had the same thing and power
outage and I just thought it and it came
on seven minutes later and we kept going
right so when this happened I was like
okay let's just wait a second it'll come
back on and then we'll just keep going
and then you know people are running
back when evacuating dramatic thing but
yeah lonely everybody got out safe so
you shut down staples and MSG that yeah
but insurance covered it's eating you
need to go on again so why was it so
important for you to do the to
reschedule it and how difficult was it
to rearrange this and make this happen
you know we were it just you know was
the venue open I I'm really working
until the end of the
year like after this there's really no
time he was just like can we seize this
moment I don't you know they were like
you don't have to do the show you know
insurance they'll cover everything
including you including the fans and
everything will be fine but I just felt
like everybody came out for this special
celebration the the crowd was so
electric that night even just for the
first 15 minutes that they got to see
and I was like you were here so I was
like I just can't leave it like that I
don't want to leave it like that they
want the experience that's what they
came for and I want to give it to them
and so I was like you know what can we
do can we do it tomorrow can we do it
the next day before we go to Boston cuz
we only had those those days and they
said we could try to make it work for
Monday and then thank God and everything
worked out perfect even Saturday the
energy was good but now it happened you
got the full show out oh man what was
the energy like in your hometown the
energy was off the charts it was it was
it was just something special in the air
I think because we got interrupted and
it looked like it wasn't gonna happen
and it could have not happened and then
to be back here for me to be able to do
this with those same people was just say
it was just it was just it was just
electric it was really electric and to
do that here in New York was was a super
special it's your birthday but they tour
yeah the date is coming closer to have
you at what did you ask for do you know
how you want to celebrate besides the
tour I haven't asked for anything know
anything you know I just I do want to
celebrate it's a big one for me so I
just wanna just wanna have a good time
I'm right at the end of the tour when uh
when my actual birthday is so I'm
probably gonna be exhausted so I just
want to do something in the afternoon
feel something nice nothing crazy but
you know just definitely several
celebrates you really are the queen of
aging backwards are you welcoming 50
with open arms because of that be you
feel better than ever you know I just
don't think of it I just think I have a
big birthday yes I'm 50 but I also feel
very useful I think of myself and kind
of like okay I say mantras to myself I'm
youthful and timeless at every age and
and that's that's my thing I don't think
we need to be defined by all the labels
that people want to put on
especially age really how you feel
inside Hustler's the trailer drops
tomorrow
the trailer is dropping tomorrow
Hustler's what was harder to train for
that movie or this tour you know
learning pole dancing was probably one
of the most challenging things I've ever
done for a film my arm is still
recovering and my back so yeah I would
say that was the hardest thing I ever
did but it was worth it I love this
character I love this story it's a
really gritty New York story women at
the forefront just real-life things like
actresses dream of yeah is what is in
this movie and to be able to produce it
in store and it was real special in that
cast I mean cardi B
among others what is it like why her
like why do you want her in this movie I
just felt like cardi was such a natural
choice much like the other girls the
constants and Lily Reinhart and Kiki and
and everybody who's in the film lizzo
everybody is just like we needed that
cast of characters to kind of make that
come to life you know we needed that
kind of personality from the girls
because the story really called for it
these were these were a special little
group of women
you